how is your screenwriting process
evolved over the years
you know it has pretty much stayed the
same you know I
I get the idea I think about the idea
don't I don't start writing anything for
a while I just sometimes I go oh that's
I didn't think about that and then I'll
find myself in the shower thinking about
it or walking down the street thinking
about it I get another little idea I get
a lot of ideas when I'm driving and
listening to music I get a lot of
inspiration suddenly out of nowhere like
oh wow that's the thing yes okay so then
eventually when I think I have enough
now to actually put something on paper
I'll open up a new document and I'll
just if I have a title for it if I don't
to just be a new story and I'll write
down whatever it is I've been thinking
about just kind of spitball it
and then I'll start returning to that
and just seeing how I can flesh that out
and ultimately try to get to a beginning
middle and an end just in the broadest
Strokes
um just to work that out and then once
I've got that
then I try actually writing an outline
so just like a scene by scene outline of
what happens next and what happens and
and from the initial page I already know
kind of where the midpoint is and I know
how I want it to end but I don't know
much else
so those little beets you know help me
and those are the most difficult things
to do because you're just pulling stuff
out of the air
um just just making stuff up which is
you know I'm complaining about it but
that's that's my job you know but it's
the hardest part of it uh and you're
just trying to build the story and build
the plot and build the characters
just piece by piece and scene by scene
and that that could take me months to to
to just keep working out and doing that
and then once I've got the outline done
um I'll try to put it aside for a while
working something else for a week or so
and then come back to it a little bit
fresh and I've had my wife read it and
and get her feedback and then um then I
just uh once I feel like I'm I've
there's always this moment and maybe one
thing has changed over the years that I
recognize it more clearly now but
there's a moment in the outline where
you feel like okay I I'm ready for the
script now uh I can't really spend any
more time speculating about what's going
to happen with this in the outline I
have to now go into this the script and
write the script and then that's a great
exciting place to be and then
um I just start writing the script and I
follow the outline uh I you take left
turns something else happens along the
way you get a different idea the
character wants to do something else so
you deviate from the outline but
basically I try to just go straight
through that process and write that
script from beginning to end and if I
get a different idea about something
that I realize could be a profound idea
for the script that's going to mean
you're working the whole First Act I'll
just again open up another document and
I'll put that idea there and then go on
and just keep writing as I get to the
end you know for me and people think oh
you're so disciplined but I think it's
actually because I'm not disciplined you
know if I don't impose this
to just go through I'll just uh you know
oh let me what I write last night that's
no good I better rewrite that you know
oh maybe it's something better at the
beginning and before you know it you
just got this jumble you don't know what
it is anymore and and that's exactly
what I would do if I didn't force myself
to go all the way through and and you
know just because it works for me
doesn't mean it work for everybody else
people have different ways of writing
you know
um uh some people depend on rewriting as
they go they can't do any other way
they've got to look at what they did
yesterday rewrite that get that perfect
as perfect as they can
uh and that's absolutely valid it works
for them but that wouldn't work for me
we talked about Stephen King in the
previous segment maybe do you have an
imaginary uh reader that you write for
he talked about that and on writing so
people are writing for someone that's
been dead for 15 years and others a
harsh High School teacher and you know
it's usually my wife Melissa okay I want
her to be impressed yeah so I really
write with the idea often of uh she'll
love this you know she'll be impressed
she'll think I'm really smart because
I've written this you know and it's
helpful you know it's uh yeah and then
it's it's just discouraging when I
realize I failed
but she doesn't always react that way to
everything I write but
um you know I learned from that and and
go on to make it better
and is there a particular style of music
you listen to you said while you're
driving you you come up with great oh
well when I'm driving I love to listen
to anything I sing and I just make a
complete fool of myself and we have a
convertible so it's even worse you know
everyone can see me there are kids
pointing at me as they drive away but I
love it I I sing I just get very
involved in the music and I you know I
love the music mostly of my era you know
I love 70s music and and I love the
classics from the 50s and 60s and
Rolling Stones and Rolling Stones and
Bruce Springsteen who still is a force
today of course uh
um I and you know just I love just
emotional kind of stuff that I can get
feelings out when I'm writing I listen
to music also but I listen to attention
to film scores
um and you know lyrics because that
would distract me but that's enormously
helpful to listen to music as I write is
and I've got an enormous collection of
scores that I listen to
so Lou Reed driving down the street and
then and then uh
how does a writer create conflict
oh well that's a great question and it's
an important one because that is really
the central thing about drama I think is
you know conflict it doesn't have to be
um people in you know major you know
fisticuffs okay I mean Catholic just be
anything where someone disagrees with
you you know a scene where two
characters agree on everything is no one
else to watch that so
um it is important I think oh even in
the most innocuous seeming scene
uh to have some sort of conflict which
is what I want is at odds with what you
want and how we're going to resolve that
and again you know I always just draw on
my personal stuff or things that drive
me crazy if it's not something overtly
obvious from the story you know this is
a bad guy here's a villain we know what
that conflict is but just when two
characters in the scene and it could be
it's just something as simple as as the
way to eat something differently one
thing that annoys the other person
um you know you crunch so loud against
it just a little things in life and then
we talked before specificity
that maybe people feel like I recognize
that yes that's like my wife you know my
husband does that
um so again it's just about being
observant and looking around you and and
watching what people do and what drives
me crazy
what is Meaningful conflict and what
isn't I think for it to be meaningful it
has to be true to who the people are
um it's got to be something that that
comes from their personalities something
that comes from their needs
as opposed to something I can't even
think of an example but you know if you
sort of impose a false conflict on two
people because you want them to fight or
you want them to be at odds with each
other but if it's not something that's
true to who they are
um then the audience just they may know
why they're disconnecting but they just
sort of Disconnect doesn't feel real
does it feel like this is this is
germane to the relationship or you know
who these people are just feels false or
can feel false
if conflict were a graph let's say in a
screenplay would there be levels maybe
small starting out but then
almost like a roller coaster absolutely
anything in a screenplay has to have you
know Peaks and valleys it just can't be
one thing all the way through even if
it's an action movie it can't be action
all the time it has to be a Break cast
you know comedy can't be you know just
multiple last because you get numb to it
after a while the Oasis gets numb and so
I feel like you really have to balance
it's a balancing act of you know we're
going to build up to this and then we're
gonna we're gonna take a breath and come
down and then build this and and that's
across all the uh the emotions really in
the script
what's your process for discovering the
emotional core of a story for me it's
just really as simple as do I feel it
you know is this a story I want to tell
because I I feel something about it that
it reverberates you know in me somewhere
um but there's I mean there's really not
a process per se that I use to come to
that or determine that or it's it's just
about emotion and do I feel it or not
you know it's kind of I mean luckily I
guess simple
and so when you're writing dialogue
um do you come back in and do that
separately do you just kind of get the
structure of the scene
no I usually at the same time sometimes
though I'll uh
because I love dialogue you know I love
writing dialogue I love listening to
these characters and and you know making
them really different from each other
and how they
but sometimes if I'm really on a roll
with a scene
and I don't want to stop to think about
a technical thing about where we are in
the scene or the characters moving are
they sitting are they leaving
uh I'll just write the dialogue like a
play
I'll just go through the scene and
finish the scene with the dialogue and
then I'll go back and and figure out
where we are you know he's moving to
here and we're making dinner you know
whatever that is
um so it doesn't seem like a play uh but
um sometimes dialogue I just it just
goes and and I just have to catch up
with it and keep up with it and do you
feel those care that's when the
characters are pushing back and they're
there's taking a a life of their own a
lot of times in the car in the dialogue
and in the behavior you know I'll
suddenly I'll write something
for the character and it's like what
doesn't sound right it's not it's not
really true this doesn't that sound like
this character talking
and I'll have to think about that I'll
try again I'll try a different word
differently it's still not it's still
fighting me
now I have to think about okay so maybe
this character doesn't want to be saying
this doesn't want to be doing this in
the scene
so what's the opposite of it what maybe
that's what we have to look at and the
same thing with behavior I'll have a
character doing something that the
reviews where they are but it feels
false it's not coming I can't get the
idea and that's when I know I can't
force it I can't you know pry it in
there I have to go back and try to
figure out what's missing
um is there and opposites are a great
writing tool so what's the exact
opposite of this and and this is not
always the answer but it helps you
sometimes get to an answer